[Music]
literally I have to tell white
videographer for these videos oh yeah
and it's some stuff out because
seriously these kick up the ass videos
they're very cool so please don't come
to me and come please don't comment on
the video say I felt a bit patronized or
your to this odd and you know just if
you're easily offended just tune off the
video right now just just skip the video
you won't like the kick up the ass
videos kick up the ass video this week I
don't want to talk about I want to talk
a little bit about service accommodation
I want to talk about rent to serviced
accommodation because there's people who
are coming on the crash course doing
some training with me and then it sounds
too good to - again if you're a skeptic
just get off the video because you won't
be able to deal with this stuff but
there's people that are coming on the
crash course and within 3 months 3
months like that's nothing with three
months they're making 10,000 pounds per
month ten thousand miles a month and
they're using a strategy which is
renting an apartment city centre
apartments maybe a thousand pound and
they pay the landlord and then they're
doing it on a rent to rent contract and
they're renting re-raising out a
serviced accommodation and the cash flow
is just ridiculous ridiculous my student
started doing this before we even make
like killing it do rings si and I was
like oh and those fingers were there I
had to check their bank and then why not
start getting some rent - si it's just
like my goodness it's just ridiculous
and here's why I'm ranting is because I
honestly believe a couple of things
number one I believe that they'll change
the rules at some point maybe in six
months or six years or who knows how
long I don't think you'll be able to do
it because what they'll do is they'll
bring in legislation like they're just
they're bringing in legislation next
June in Ireland to say that you need em
you can't do it anymore you can't you
can't do Rome - si
okay I want to go to the details of why
and all that but you can't do it right
in the center of London you can only do
it for 90 days
so article form is just coming in I
don't know how long we'll be in the
merge in generally in England how long
you can do this strategy for but what I
do know is one of the prediction is that
when they change the rules
people will look back at these days 2018
2019 these days inside and this was what
we're really in every time when people
will look back inside those were the
days you know those with a good day
those were the good days because
everybody always says those are the good
days but everybody's saying now these
are the days and let me say something
these are the days right now but I don't
anymore saying that knows it all these
are the days right now there's people
selling their portfolios because they're
scared of brick set right now those
people still in negative equity far up
north they want you to buy their houses
off them for free on a lease option
agreement these are the days these are
the days right now you can rent a house
and then we rent it on serviced
accommodation and make ten thousand
pounds a month with it a handful of
deals these are the days please don't be
one of these people that say those were
the days those were the days as well
2008 you could buy a property refinance
it the same day and pull all your money
out
guess what Kenny lights are just
scrapped abolished the six-month rule so
you can now buy a house as long as you
have value to it you can refinance it
with no time limit whatsoever
they just abolish the six-month rule
these are the days so get educated you
know some of you guys man some of you
guys cut I do not want to hear another
excuse as to why you are or anyone is
stuck in their job or can't do it I
haven't got money I haven't got that
just remember these are the days take
action if you agree with this video
please share it if you disagree
with this video please go subscribe to
another channel because I don't want to
hear it because I'm right on this I'm a
hundred percent right on this if you
disagree go subscribe somewhere else
come back in five years and then tell me
I was wrong boom
[Music]